So today we are going to continue
where we left off last time talking
more specifically about variations
on the theme of life.
And last year I tried to do this
lecture using PowerPoint and it was
a total disaster so I'm going back
to the board.  You will have the
PowerPoint slides.
They'll be on the Web to download
to summarize basically what I'm
drawing on the board.
But it will be slightly different on
the board.  But I found that for
this material it really doesn't work
to exclusively use the PowerPoint.
So last time we talked about,
remember, my life on earth
abridged where --
-- we had photosynthesis making
glucose or organic carbon plus
oxygen?  And then the reverse of
this was respiration.
And then we had elements cycling in
the middle.  And I said this is very,
very abbreviated of how all life on
earth works.  And so today what I'm
going to do is tell you that that's
not right.  That's grossly
oversimplified.
And there are some really
interesting variations on the theme
of how to extract energy and carbon
and reducing power and electrons
from the earth's system
to create life.
And it's mostly microbes that have
these diverse possibilities.
And, again, even what I'm going to
talk to you about today is
oversimplified.
If you go to a microbiology
textbook you'll find just about
every possible combination of energy
sources, carbon sources and electron
sources in some microorganisms
somewhere to get through life.
So I'm giving you,
again, the simplified version
because otherwise it gets way too
complicated.  So all of life needs
carbon and energy,
and a lot of other elements,
too, but these are the main axis
upon which we're going to order our
universe today.
So for carbon the choices are
inorganic or organic.
So this would be CO2 and this might
be glucose or sugars,
any sugars.  And then on the energy
axis they can use solar energy,
as in photosynthesis, or they can
use chemical energy.
And within the chemical energy
sources they can be inorganic or
organic like sugars, etc.
And often here you have reduced
compounds such as hydrogen sulfide,
ammonia, and we'll talk about these.
So these are the ways we divide up
the possibilities for carbon and
energy sources to be alive.
All organisms also need to have an
energy currency in the cell.
And you've talked about this a lot
already in the biochemistry lectures
so I'm, again,
just giving you the impressionist
view of this.  You know the details.
This is just to get you organized.
And so all life uses
redox reactions.
And in your handouts for today
there's a primer on redox reactions
just in case you want to review that.
And one of the key reactions we'll
talk about today is the conversion
of NADP.  If you put energy in you
can reduce it to NADPH.
So that's a reduction.
And the reverse you get energy out
when it's oxidized.
Now, we're going to be talking
about oxidation and reduction today.
And then they all use ATP which
you've talked a lot about here.
And the couple here is ADP.  Put
energy in.
You make ATP which is a high energy
intermediate.  And in converting it
back to ADP that energy can be
released.  And this is used in the
biochemistry of the cell.
So all cells have these two energy
conversion processes in common.
OK, so let's look at just
summarizing what we're going to go
over today.  This is a summary of
options for life.
See also Freeman,
Chapter 25.  There is some
discussion of this.
And we can divide life here between
what we call autotrophs.
These are organisms that can make
their own organic carbon.
In other words, they can convert
carbon dioxide to organic carbon.
Heterotrophs are organisms that can
only use organic carbon.
They rely on the guts of other
organisms in order to
get through life.
And so now we're going to
systematically go through these
processes that fall under each one
of these.  Oxygenic photosynthesis
is the one we've been talking about
last time and in my abbreviated
version of life on earth.
And this is carried out by
eukaryotic organisms,
plants, trees, etc., and also by
prokaryotic organisms.
Those are the cyanobacteria,
microscopic photosynthetic plants.
They use CO2 and sunlight.
So our first variant on this theme
we'll get into is a group of
bacteria that do anoxygenic
photosynthesis.
Oxygenic means they evolve oxygen.
These guys use solar energy but
they don't evolve oxygen.
And we'll get into how that works.
And then there's a group of
organisms that still use CO2.
And in the very similar pathway the
Calvin Cycle is photosynthesis.
But they use chemical energy in
order to make these intermediates to
fix CO2.  OK, so let's talk about
those first.  And so we're going to
talk about the autotrophs.
And all of them share this
pathway, CO2 to C6H12.
This would be glucose.
And it takes ATP to run this
reaction and it also takes
reduced NADPH --
-- to run this reaction.
It also takes this enzyme ribisco
which you've talked about I'm sure,
ribulose bisphosphate carboxylase.
And this is the enzyme that
initially takes the CO2 from the
atmosphere and binds it
to an organic carbon.
Now, in a detailed version of this
is what's called the Calvin Cycle or
the Calvin/Benson Cycle.
I don't know which one your book
calls it.  Calvin got the Nobel
Prize but Benson was the graduate
student that did all the work,
so you should recognize that.
Anyway, you studied this in great
deal.  But an interesting factoid is
that ribisco is the most abundant
protein on earth.
That tells you how important this
reaction is for sustaining
life on earth.
So notice that in order to drive
this reaction,
which is the Calvin Cycle,
it requires energy and reducing
power.  So where do they get it?
Well, there are three ways that
autotrophs can get energy and
reducing power to drive this
reaction.  And the first is oxygenic
photosynthesis.  And the
second is anoxygenic.
And the third is chemosynthesis.
OK, those first three there.  So
now we're going to go through each
of these and look at how they work
remembering that all of them are
generating ATP and NADPH in order to
drive that.  So all of the
autotrophs have that in common.
Well, oxygenic photosynthesis is the
one that you know well already.
You've studied it in great detail
in biochemistry.
So we're going to,
again, give you the abbreviated
version here just so you have a
template to map these
other ones onto.
These are what are known as the
light reactions of photosynthesis,
the Z scheme taking solar energy,
splitting water,
evolving oxygen and synthesizing ATP
and NADPH.  This is all familiar,
right?  Very familiar.  I'm just
writing it in a cartoon version.
OK, so this is the NADPH and ADP
that goes to fuel that process.
OK, so now, well,
at least I can do it on that board.
Let me do it on this board.
Anoxygenic --
-- is almost exactly like this
process, but instead of splitting
water these guys oxidize hydrogen
sulfide.  So here's
our ATP and NADPH.
And they use sunlight to do this.
So these are called photosynthetic
bacteria.  And they were around very
early on the earth.
Long before the earth's atmosphere
was oxygenated these were the guys
that were able to use solar energy
and make organic carbon but without
evolving oxygen.
Then somewhere along the line some
cell evolved, had some mutations and
somehow figured out that water,
this abundant source of water was a
much better electron donor than
hydrogen sulfide.
And once the biochemistry figured
this out, you can see the simple
substitution here,
the whole earth started going in a
different direction.
So this is an interesting example
of how a small biochemical
innovation can dramatically change
the whole nature of the planet.
Now, these guys are still around on
earth.  In fact,
I'm going to show you some.
I'll explain this at the end,
but I have some captured in here.
See that little purple band?  Those
are those guys.
I've got other little tricks in
here but I'll save those.
Well, you cannot really see the
purple band.  But you can come up
later and look at it.
Those are photosynthetic bacteria.
So they're still around on the
earth but they're stuck in places
where there's no oxygen.
So they have a rather restricted
niche on the planet now,
but they're still extremely
important.  What did I
do?  Oh, here it is.
So one of the places that they can
be found, and if you're interested
in them a great place to go find
some is out at the Mystic Lakes in
Arlington which is a permanently
stratified lake so the bottom of the
lake is always anaerobic.
There's never oxygen there.
In a typical lake like that you
have a lot of mud on the bottom and
you have a lot of hydrogen sulfide
coming out of the mud from bacterial
processes that we'll talk about.
And you have light here.
And so you have a gradient here of
this is oxygen and this is H2S.
And these photosynthetic bacteria
have to life somewhere where there's
enough light to photosynthesize and
enough hydrogen sulfide to use in
this part of the reaction.
But they're very sensitive to oxygen
so they cannot be in the oxygenated
part of the lake.
So you find them in a layer.
It's called the squeeze.  They have
to have light so they have to be up,
but they cannot have oxygen so they
have to be down.
And they need hydrogen sulfide so
they have to be down.
So they're layered in lakes.
OK.  So what about these guys,
chemosynthesis?
They don't rely on solar energy.
Again, they're still driving the
Calvin Cycle reducing CO2 from the
air into organic carbon,
but they're not using sunlight.
So what do they do?  They get their
energy --
-- from redox reactions.
And let's just show you an example.
Redox reactions couple to the
conversion of oxygen to H2O.
So oxygen is involved in these
reactions.  And one organism,
for example, can take ammonia and
convert it to nitrite.
Another type of organism can take
nitrite and convert it to nitrate.
And there are other organisms that
can take hydrogen sulfide and
convert it to sulfate.
And some can take hydrogen sulfide,
oh, no, take iron, ferrous iron,
Fe2+ and convert it to Fe3+.
So in all of these cases what is
happening to these compounds?
Are they being oxidized or reduced?
I heard an oxidized.  Yes, they're
being oxidized.
So these reduced compounds,
relatively reduced compounds can be
utilized by oxidizing them.
The organism can release the energy
that's needed.  ATP
is generated here.
And NADPH is generated by any of
these redox couples.
So using this energy then the cell
takes the reduced NADPH and the ATP
and it runs the Calvin Cycle,
chemosynthesis.  OK.  Now, you may
think that these are kind of strange,
weird bacteria that life in strange
pockets of the earth where there's
no oxygen.  And who cares anyway?
They're outdated.
They dominated the earth way back
in the early stages of the earth but
they're not so important now.
Well, that's not true.  They're
incredibly important.
In some ecosystems they're the
total base of the entire ecosystem.
But also on a global scale, as
you'll learn, you should have a
feeling for this by the end of this
lecture, but also when we talk about
global biogeochemical cycles you
will learn that these microbes are
really messengers for electrons in
the environment.
Without them the redox balance of
the earth would not be maintained,
OK?  You cannot have nothing but
oxidizing reactions or nothing but
reduction reactions and have a
system sustain itself.
So it's these microbes that are
playing a really important role in
maintaining the redox balance
of the earth.  OK.
Now, one system that I'm going to
show you in that DVD,
that will do much better justice to
it than my drawings here,
that's a deep-sea volcano in case
you didn't recognize it.
And this is 2500 meters at the
bottom of the ocean,
very, very deep.  And there is
intense heat.  I mean just think of
a volcano on the surface
of the earth.
Intense heat and reduced compounds
are found in the earth's mantle that
are ready to erupt through this
deep-sea volcano.
And you have sulfate in the sea
water that percolates through here.
And as it percolates in and gets
draw into the volcanic stuff that's
coming out of here it's reduced to
hydrogen sulfide coming
out of the volcano.
But you have oxygen in the water in
the deep-sea. And we'll be talking
about this when we talk about ocean
circulation.  But the oceans have a
global ocean circulation where the
surface water that's in equilibrium
with the atmosphere actually sinks
and travels along the bottom of the
ocean.  So there is oxygen in the
bottom of the ocean,
unlike many lakes where you don't
have oxygen.
And we'll talk about that difference.
And in the hot vents the water
coming out of here can be very,
very hot, but there's a gradient
right as it comes out meeting the
colder sea water.
And so what you have here is a
perfect incubator for chemosynthetic
bacteria --
-- that use the hydrogen sulfide in
chemosynthesis to fix carbon dioxide
using the oxygen here.
And that forms the base of the
entire food web in the deep ocean
because there's no light down there.
There's no photosynthesis.  There's
only chemosynthesis.
And just a little story that goes
back to when I first came to MIT as
an assistant professor in 1976.
You weren't even born.  But when I
was young we used to go the Muddy
Charles Pub periodically after work
and have beers.
And there was a professor,
in this department actually,
John Edmond, who passed away several
years ago but who used to be there.
It was sort of like our Cheers.
And I'll never forget the day he
came back from a cruise.
He came to the pub.  He was a
chemist and I'm a biologist.
And he said you will not believe
what we found on the bottom of the
ocean.  He had gone down in Alvin,
this two-person submersible vehicle.
And he started talking about these
giant clams and these giant tube
worms and all of these things,
and I thought he had had one too
many beers.  I found it hard to
believe.  Well,
it turned out that that was the
first discovery of these deep-sea
vents and he was on that expedition.
And through that collegial
relationship I actually ended up
with one of the clam shells from the
clams there, which is one
of the giant clams.
Their meat is blood red because they
have a special kind of hemoglobin
that they use to keep the oxygen
tension perfect for these
chemosynthetic bacteria.
If the oxygen is too high they
cannot do this because it will
spontaneously oxidize the H2S.
So the oxygen tension is very
critical.
And they have a special kind of
hemoglobin that does that.
So these claims had symbiotic
chemosynthetic bacteria.
Well, since then these vents have
been discovered everywhere and
ecosystems similar have been
discovered on the surface.
And there are all kinds of
different vents.
You're going to learn about not
only hydrothermal vents,
hot vents in this video, but also
cold seeps they're called where you
have methane bacteria that are
really important.  OK.
So these are the main ways in which
organisms can get energy to convert
CO2 to organic carbon.
Then you have all these
heterotrophs, the ones that use the
organic carbon,
and they have various ways of doing
that.  You've learned in
biochemistry the primary way,
which is very powerful, and that is
using aerobic respiration
to do that.
And so we are just going to
abbreviate that here.
That's our reverse of
photosynthesis.  So heterotrophs.
So we have first aerobic.
And let me jump ahead
with the slides.
OK, there you are.
So this is a cartoon version of
aerobic respiration.
So we'll just put glucose,
we'll come down to the Krebs' Cycle.
And we are going to let electrons
flow here and have oxygen be the
final electron acceptor
creating water.
So we've really just accomplished
the absolute reverse of
photosynthesis and we've made NADH
in doing this and we've made ATP.
So these guys are getting the
energy out of the glucose that all
of the other organisms made.
And oxygen is the terminal electron
acceptor when there's
oxygen around.
But there are lots of environments,
as we've talked about on earth,
where there isn't oxygen.
And there are bacteria that can
take advantage of those environments.
And instead of having oxygen be the
terminal electron acceptor there are
a number of other elements that they
can use, compounds that they can use.
For example, there are some that
use nitrate and they reduce
it to nitrous oxide.
N2.  Ammonia.  All the relatively
reduced forms of nitrogen.
And so this called anaerobic.
And this process is called
gentrification.
And if it weren't for these bacteria,
these anaerobic bacteria that can
reduce nitrate,
nitrogen would never return to the
atmosphere.  Remember last time we
talked about nitrogen fixation,
how specific types of microbes can
take N2 from the atmosphere and pull
it into the ecosystem?
Well, if you didn't have these
bacteria doing this process that
nitrogen would never get
back to the atmosphere.
They're central to closing the
nitrogen cycle.
Then there are some that can use
sulfate and reduce it to hydrogen
sulfide.  As you can imagine,
these are critical to creating the
hydrogen sulfide that's used in
these other processes.
There are some that use CO2 and
convert to methane.
These are methanogenic bacteria,
and they're incredibly important in
the global carbon cycle and
in the methane cycle.
Methane is a really powerful
greenhouse gas,
and we're going to talk about that
later.  And then there are some that
can take Fe3+ and reduce it to Fe2+.
And the same for manganese.
So you should be starting to sense a
sort of symmetry here,
right, that these anaerobic bacteria
are fulfilling functions on the
earth.  Let me write these down.
These are sulfate reducers,
these are methanogens, and these are
iron reducers and manganese
reducers.
So these will all become extremely
important when we talk about the
global biogeochemical cycles of all
of these elements.
It's these microbes that make sure
that the cycles can continue and
don't run into a dead end of
oxidation or reduction.
OK.  Before we go to the movie,
I just want to say if you look at
Table 25.2 in your textbook,
I think it's that one.
I'm assuming I'm using the most
recent version.
You'll see a variation of this
theme in which there will be some
entries of organisms that don't fall
into these categories that
I've just shown you.
And that is to say that there are
organisms that use light energy and
organic carbon energy at the same
time.  For every variation that's
possible there's an organism that's
evolved to take advantage of it.
I've just oversimplified it here,
but you should know that.  And the
bottom line is if it's
thermodynamically possible.
And, again, this whole lecture could
have been done in a thermodynamic
mode.  We could have looked at which
redox couples were energetically
possible and then assigned those to
particular microbes.
But for now I just want you to get
the overview.  But for anything
that's thermodynamically feasible
there's a microbe out there
that's doing it.
And, in fact, microbiologists
actually comb through redox tables
and put together different redox
couples and hypothesize.
I ought to be able to find an
organism that does this in that
environment.  And then they go out.
And they can almost always actually
find it.  So they're incredibly
versatile.  And it gives you a
really good strong feeling for the
power of thermodynamics in driving
the evolution of these biochemical
processes.
Finally, before we show you the
movie I want to show you what this
thing is all about.
There was a Russian microbiologist
back in the previous century
named Winogradsky --
-- who wanted to isolate some of
these photosynthetic bacteria.
And knowing what their
characteristics were he went out and
got himself some mud and some pond
water.  And he set up what we've
come to call a Winogradsky column.
This is a Winogradsky juice bottle,
but it works the same.  And what you
do is you put mud in the bottom and
you put pond water here.
And the pond water has basically an
inoculum.  It has representatives of
all different types of bacteria.
They might be spores.  If they
don't like the environment they're
in they sporulates and then they
just don't germinate.
But presumably in pond water you
have everything that could possibly
grow in here.  And in the mud you
add a source of sulfate.
And so you might add calcium
sulfate and you might add a little
organic matter,
you know, plant parts or something
just to jumpstart it.
And eventually you set up a gradient
here of hydrogen sulfide and oxygen.
And over time the organisms grow
along that gradient.
So you'll end up down here with the
anaerobic respiration.
In fact, the organisms generate this
gradient.  When you start out the
whole thing is oxygenated.
And what you should think about in
this context is what happens.
How do these gradients get
generated when you start out with a
completely mixed system,
everything in there, everything
oxygenated?  Eventually
you have anaerobic --
First you'll just have anaerobic
respiration, right?
Anything that can use organic
carbon and oxygen is going to go
like mad, and that's what's going to
draw the oxygen down.
Then you'll have anaerobic
respiration here.
You'll have photosynthesis up here,
evolving oxygen.  You'll have
chemosynthetic bacteria here because
they need a little bit of oxygen but
they also need some of this hydrogen
sulfide and photosynthetic
bacteria here.
Well, they're like down here.
Because they need light but cannot
have oxygen.  And so you can set
these up.  And this purple band here
tells you that you've got your
photosynthetic bacteria.